BACK TO WORK.
THEY DESPERATELY NEEDED.
>> Ed: ABSOLUTELY.
CASEY STEGALL.
>> Sandra: FORM ON THIS LET’S
BRING IN THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
OF TEXAS, DAN PATRICK.
SO WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
EXPECTATIONS AS FAR AS WHEN WE
DO SEE AT LEAST SOME OF THE
BUSINESSES IN TEXAS REOPEN LATER
THIS WEEK.
>> LIKE ALL THE MEN OUT THERE I
WANT THEM.
IT’S A TEAM EFFORT, AND THAT’S
29, AND PUT US IN THIS POSITION.
WHAT I SAID YESTERDAY AT THE
PRESS CONFERENCE WAS WE NEED
THEM TO CONTINUE.
WE DON’T NEED TO MANDATE A SOME
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE MASKS,
AND OUR EXECUTIVE ORDERS
OVERRIDE THOSE LOCAL BORDERS.
WE RECOMMEND THAT YOU WEAR A
MASK AND WE STILL RECOMMEND YOU
SAVE DISTANCING.
WE WANT TO GET FULL INTO OUR
ECONOMY, AND WE WANT THE
RESTAURANT AND THE BUSINESSES.
WE WANT ALL OF THESE BUSINESSES
TO BE OPEN AND TO DO THAT WE
NEED THE TEAM EFFORT.
LOOK.
WE ARE, EVERY LIFE IS PRECIOUS,
AND AS WE LOOK AT THIS PER
CAPITA, WITH LOST A LITTLE OVER
700 PEOPLE.
THAT’S 70 PLUS, I HAD A LOT OF
HEALTH ISSUES.
SO WE ARE LOOKING AT THIS, AND
WE BELIEVE THAT OUR TEXANS, AND
WE THINK PER CAPITA THAT’S THE
LARGEST OF THE WORLD.
IT’S TIME TO GET BACK TO WORK,
AND FOR EVERYONE, YOU CAN GET
BACK OUT THERE, WEAR A MASK AND
BE CAREFUL BUT, WEAR A MASK AND
STAY IN A LITTLE BIT LONGER AS
THE GOVERNOR SAID.
GET UP AND RUNNING FULL SPEED
VERY QUICKLY.
>> BUT OF COURSE, THOSE YOUNGER
FOLKS COULD SPREAD IT TO THE
OLDER FOLKS, AND YOU ARE MAKING
A REFERENCE AND YOU ARE HIGHLY
CRITICIZED.
IN ESSENCE, YOU ARE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE SOME WIVES TO KEEP THE
ECONOMY GOING OR AT LEAST
REOPEN.
SO HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU IN THIS
STAGE IN THE GAME THAT THIS IS
THE RIGHT MOVE FOR TEXAS AND
THAT THIS DOES NOT JEOPARDIZE
LIVES TO REOPEN AT LEAST SOME OF
THESE BUSINESSES.
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE ARE NOT
TELLING ANYONE THAT GOES AT THAT
BUSINESS, BUT ON THE COMMENTS
YOU JUST MADE SANDRA, THAT’S NOT
WHAT I SAID.
I DIDN’T SAY WE WERE WILLING TO
SACRIFICE LIVES AND THAT’S WHAT
THE LEFT HAS SAID AND SPUN IT.
AND THAT’S WHAT TUCKER SAID, IT
WAS TOTALLY TAKEN OUT OF CONTEXT
AND THIS REPORTED.
COULD I HAVE ARTFULLY SAID IT
BETTER, MAYBE.
BUT THIS IS A SHARED EFFORT BY
ALL OF US.
WE HAVE TO PROTECT OUR
POPULATION OF SENIORS, BUT I’M A
SENIOR.
SENIORS NEED TO BE CAREFUL.
WE DON’T HAVE TO SHUT THE
ECONOMY DOWN AT THE SAME TIME.
I HAVE THIS WATERING HOLE THEORY
AND IT’S THIS.
EVERYONE GOES TO THE WATER HOLE
IN THE OLD DAYS OR THEY BRING
BACK WATER TO EVERYONE.
OUR MODERN DAY WATERING HOLE
SANDRA IS THE GROCERY STORE.
AND SINCE DAY ONE, AND TEXAS ALL
29 MILLION OF US HAVE BEEN TO
THE GROCERY STORE OR WE LIVE
WITH SOMEONE WHO HAS COME BACK
FROM THE GROCERY STORE AND WE
HAVEN’T SEEN THIS HUGE OUTBREAK.
AND THE GROCERY STORE WORKERS
HAVE PUT THEMSELVES AT RISK, AND
THEY HAVEN’T SEEN THIS HUGE
OUTBREAK OF OVERWHELMING OUR
HOSPITALS.
WE HAVEN’T SEEN THIS HUGE
OUTBREAK IN TEXAS, AND THAT’S
SOMETHING WE’VE ALL BEEN DOING
IN THIS COUNTRY.
OR LIVING WITH SOMEONE WHO DID
AND WE HAVEN’T HAD THIS MASSIVE
OUTBREAK THAT WE WERE ALL TOLD
WE WERE GOING TO HAVE.
AND WHY CAN’T WE GO TO ANY
STORE, BECAUSE ANY STORE OWNER
IN ANY BUSINESS IS JUST AS SMART
AS THE GROCERY STORE.
THEY CAN DO IT IN THE SAME WAY.
>> Sandra: TO BE SURE, WE’D
SEEN AN OVERWHELMING AMOUNT OF
DEATHS AND AN ILLNESS IS IN THIS
COUNTRY AS A RESULT OF THIS BUT
THE GROCERY STORE COULD BE A
DIFFERENT SCENARIO, BECAUSE YOU
COULD SOCIAL DISTANCE WHEN YOU
WALK IN THE DOOR.
BUT IN BARBER BARBERSHOPS YOU
CAN’T -- >> WE HAVE TO LEAVE IT
UP TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
AMERICAN BUSINESS PERSON TO SET
THAT UP.
PEOPLE ARE SMART.
AND THE HAIR SALONS AND THE
BARBERSHOPS, THEY WILL BE SMART.
PEOPLE AREN’T GOING TO GO TO A
PLACE THAT’S NOT SAFE.
IT’S INCUMBENT UPON THOSE
BUSINESSES THAT WE GO TO TO BE
SMART AND MAKE PEOPLE SAFE SO
THEY WILL COME.
MY POINT IS, IF YOU CAN DO IT IN
A GROCERY STORE WHERE WE’VE ALL
BEEN, THERE’S NO DENYING THAT.
EVERYONE IN AMERICA HAS BEEN
THERE AND LIVES WITH SOMEONE,
WHY CAN’T WE DO THAT IN EVERY
PLACE AND EVERY BUSINESS AND
LEAVE IT UP IN THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
REPUBLICANS AND THE DEMOCRATS IN
THIS, IF YOU LOOK AT ALL THE
STATES AND ALL THE COUNTY’S AND
ALL THE CITIES, IT’S DEMOCRATS.
>> Sandra: I’M SORRY TO TALK
OVER JO, I WILL HAVE TO WRAP YOU
THERE.
OBVIOUSLY THE MEDICAL COMMUNITY
SAID THE IDEA WAS TO FLATTEN THE
CURVE AND ONLY GO OUT IF YOU
HAVE TOO.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON, WILL
FOLLOW-UP WITH YOU AND WE ARE
WATCHING WHAT’S HAPPENING IN